Let me begin by repeating my last point in,
uh,
last Tuesday's lecture.
The,
uh,
birth of don't get hotter is an act of self invention by a man of 50.
And remember that fifties,
a very advanced age in 1605,
he feels free to create himself beyond family births and need in this,
the novel is directly opposed to most previous literature,
particularly the romances of Chicory where they were miraculous births and the
picaresque very much in particular the picker asking in which family background
and need determined the life of the protagonist or so he claims as he tells us
life,
uh,
is,
is poverty.
Uh,
on the,
uh,
the family,
background weighs heavily on the rest of his life.
In the case of the Pickerel,
Don Quixote is beyond family and social determinism.
In most bring your stories,
young people leave home in search of adventures that will give substance meaning
and individuality,
individuality to their lives.
Can you think of another old protagonist before Gnocchi?
Haughty.
How old was the pink,
the pilgrim in the divine comedy?
I think it was 33.
How was Odysseus in the Odyssey?
How old nes and the need.
So let's Tinnitus.
True was old,
but she shares the limelight with young lovers.
Donkey hotter as I think I said in the last class is beyond Freud,
beyond the family romance.
In fact,
though,
we learn a great deal about him in the first chapter.
We learn nothing of his,
of his parents.
His genealogy is literary the books that he has read.
Uh,
the most innovative aspect of Don Quixote,
uh,
is the characters self fashioning as,
Steve Greenblatt would put it in,
in,
in a book called Renaissance self fashioning a,
the reader witnesses this self transformation,
uh,
in all its level from the mental to the physical,
from one don Quixote thinks to what he wears.
He not an author names him,
his horse and his lady,
his is a life that will be molded like a work of art.
Life are,
uh,
will imitate art.
But what is the significance of this self invention,
uh,
of this resurrection?
I said,
where
renaissance humanism emphasize the power of human agency.
Uh,
it is the beginning of a liberation from a God centered conception of the world
out of humankind.
Remember the Lucaj quote,
uh,
about the today being the first,
story,
uh,
of a world that has been abandoned by God.
So in this world,
abandoned by God,
man creates himself.
Don Quixote creates himself
and know Lugarda della [inaudible].
This is the first sentence of the book.
Uh,
Jarvis translates in a village of Lemont Chia,
the name of which I purposely omit their lived long ago.
Uh,
this is a sentence by the way,
that most limited native speakers of Spanish know by heart,
even if they haven't read the rest of the keyhole.
Uh,
and the,
the disclaimer,
the cool you're known,
but a Nokia or go to that to me is also used in conversation to say,
I don't want to remember this.
Uh,
now it is known the way that English speakers,
no,
it was the best of times.
It was the worst of times,
a tale of two cities or call me Ishmael,
uh,
the beginning of Moby Dick,
and so forth.
Uh,
in the Quixote literature appears as I've been saying,
I said realm of self legitimation and the display of wit and capacity for
invention,
which is what Cervantes appears to be affirming in the first sentence of the
book.
He does not wish as a narrator,
he does not wish to remember the place in Manchuria where Don Quixote lived.
It is a display of authorial will.
The sentence is full of other implications.
Uh,
there is the echo of the opening of traditional stories as well as that of
official document that our test to ones being by stating we're one is from in
the stories in such a such a country long ago and the country is named or my
name is such and so,
and I live in such and such a place and was born in such and such a place,
illegal document to make such a statement is once a strongest form of grounding.
Uh,
but here willfully omitted that place name that is erased by the creative.
We'll have the author,
I know [inaudible],
I don't want to remember it.
Uh,
against the traditional formulas,
uh,
in which it is given the origin,
this origin,
this place,
this village,
this Lou Gehrig as his calling in the 16th century Spanish,
uh,
to which,
the protagonist returns several times and definitively at the end is not named.
It is us as eve here the source where non determining as the age of Don Quixote
is non determining in his subsequent adventures.
This is perhaps the reason why the origin,
which is also a destination because knowing how they will return to die at home.
Giving away the plot here,
sorry.
Uh,
this is the perhaps a recent way the origin which is also a destination is left
blank deliberately effaced uh,
from the store.
It is,
it is a non place,
although many towns in Spain claim to be the,
the town in which,
uh,
Loki hope there was born.
Now Don Quixote has name and other names we have already or have already spoken
about,
uh,
Kosaki Hala Hannah.
And by now you have read all of these variations of the potential,
uh,
potential variations of the,
of uh,
along Soki harness,
first name.
Uh,
Eh,
the point is,
is it's also one,
uh,
prevalent throughout the book the fluctuations of language in reference to
meaning and to truth.
If language is so shifty,
how can we express the truth in language?
Uh,
Spitzer,
Leo Spitzer,
a great German critic who worked,
uh,
in this country for many years,
and taught at Johns Hopkins University in the piece on linguistic perspectivism
that you will read in your casebook makes much of this and he makes much of this
with the knowledge of the linguist and philology philologists that he was,
you will,
you will see a language and its vagaries also constitutes Cervantes point of
view about what is commonly accepted as the truth and how the truth can be
commonly accepted in a medium,
a shifty,
uh,
as,
as language
but the blurry name,
the whole [inaudible] so and so forth.
It's also a way of playing with the absence of determinism as being from the
Manchuria and non place.
A,
I said,
we're a name and a place marked the characters in the epic and in the Romances
of chivalry and even the picaresque novels,
I'm,
are these,
the goals of Gore Lasa [inaudible] storm is,
is the river that goes through Salamanca by the way,
in which the picker was supposed to have been born.
Goose Monday,
Alpha Rashi place there,
his name Al Farace,
but not,
not in the Kihatha significantly.
Now Don Quixote names is lady do scenario.
They'll torso and Rosina Auntie in the first case,
uh,
the lady he follows literary convention,
her name rhymes with Melly where,
who is the,
uh,
one of the protagonist of a is Tina.
The beautiful young woman.
And dual say means sweet in Spanish.
So,
uh,
you can see the,
the,
the origin and the intention behind naming Douchey,
Neha,
that while the horses name reflects something,
something of his reality,
the Nantais,
the raw thing,
anti meaning he was at Racine,
a work horse before,
and this is before in Spanish or Rossie.
Manti.
The name does reflect in a very direct and comical way because of this
director's precisely,
uh,
the reality about this.
Uh,
this nag
don't be Hotez.
Capacity for naming as we will see is quite extraordinary.
He's a man of words and of the word,
but the crucial point here is that he's naming himself his lady on his horse as
part of this process of self invention.
Uh,
like Adam giving names to things in the garden of Eden or God giving names to
things.
This is part and parcel of the process of self invention.
I repeat.
Okay.
Now we move on to chapter two,
which is one of the most to me,
remarkable moments in all of literature the protagonist has created himself and
he leaves at dawn the beginning of a new day of a new life and sets out on them
on Teal plane alone.
It is a willed beginning from zero,
from a voluntary severing of ties with any possible determining force except for
the loss of chivalry and for literature.
It is a moment of freedom of freedom,
achieved freedom from the past.
But as he goes along the,
he anticipates Don Quixote anticipates the literary texts that would be written
about the exploits that he is in the process of accomplishment,
accomplishing all that he thinks he's in the process of accomplishing.
There is a gap of course,
between the high flown rhetoric of the romances of chivalry that he uses and the
little plane is a plane up of which he gallops or trucks Frawley.
Uh,
but this is precisely the gap between literature and reality between writing and
experience that will be at the core of serve anthesis exploration of the nature
of writing,
uh,
the present and the writing of the tech's hands.
Somewhere in between the reality and these high flown rhetoric,
uh,
the,
that are parallel on simultaneously in their appearance in the book.
This is quite remarkable and it may pass on notice,
but I want you to take notice of it.
Uh,
uh,
is,
on the translation where using pages 26,
27 a don Quixote,
I see goals or on the plane,
uh,
have Montiel,
says to himself who doubt but that in future times when the faithful history of
my famous exploits all come to light,
the sage who writes them,
when he gives a relation of this,
my first Halley so early in the morning,
we'll do it in words like this,
quote,
scar scarcely had the Rudy or Roddy fevers spread the golden tresses of his
beauty,
his hair over the face of the widened spacious Earth Ans Kearsley had the
painted birds with the Sweden mellifluous harmony of their fork tongs saluted
the approach of Rosie Aurora who quitting the soft couch of her jealous husband
and so forth and so on.
Uh,
these using all of these references to classical mythology to refer to himself
as he projects the text that will be written about him.
Now
he arrives at the,
we know,
and this is a effect to remember
from the episode in the,
in that donkey hotel leaves home on a hot Friday in July.
How do we know this?
We know it because they serve fish.
Do Don Quixote at the,
in explaining that the eating of red meat is for bitten on Fridays by the
Catholic Church.
It was until the 1960s of the past century.
So it is clear because it is a hot day and it is the month of July that this is
a hot Friday in July.
This specificity of time and place is a new feature of fiction of this realist
fiction.
As we saw the romances of chivalry took place in vague fabulous countries and
times,
not techie holiday,
which derived from the picker Escott pension for the particular in everything.
It is the birth of what we know as realism,
whose origins and intention I spoke about in the last lecture,
interest in society or its lowest level and the acquisition,
acquisition of aesthetic value by the sordid,
the ugly and the dirty.
Now the heat,
uh,
by the way it would presumably,
and it says,
so in the text,
uh,
contribute to don Quixote's madness according to theories of the,
of the time,
which are probably not altogether wrong.
If you're out in the desert in the heat,
you might lose,
uh,
your census to put the weather.
The weather is important for other reasons in the Quixote,
a specific whether or not the fabulous weather mists and all of that in the
romances of chivalry,
both parts of the novel take place in a vaguely framed summer
in part because a heat contributes to don Quixote's madness,
as I say,
but also because it makes it logical for everyone to be outdoors on the road.
We'll see a little bit more about,
uh,
Hawaii people are on the road.
Um,
the song song,
the very important issue that begins in these early chapters already of light
and visibility,
being able to discern objects and make them out and,
uh,
which leads to disputes between the two protagonists about the nature of what
they see.
Uh,
if you have been to Spain and took a steel,
you know that uh,
the air is clear,
it is a hot and dry and the visibility is uh,
uh,
very,
very good.
This first in is crucial because it sets up one of the most important places
where the action will develop ins as you will soon discover.
Waystations stations are waystations where all sorts of meetings take place and
hilarious scenes develop.
The Quixote follows the loose structure of the adventure book,
like the Romances of chivalry that he parodies but also like the pickers.
So it needs the,
these inns us waypoints were characters from various origins and classes meet
the income provided kind of archeology of society and moveable home,
four characters away from home.
What I mean by an archeology of society,
he say you see at the same time,
but I swear you make a cut on the earth to study the various layers.
Uh,
the,
the here you see there is layers of social classes or pressing at the same time.
In the end,
this is where the ind provides what I call an archeology of,
of society.
It is not the end that we encounter for the first time.
Don Quixote's ability to transform a crass reality into a literary elution.
Although he has done some of that in naming of course his,
his horse,
that process that is highlighted by the fact that he is confronted with the
extreme of crassness of crassness,
no ordinary women.
Those he turned into damn sauce but horse,
not ordinary travelers but swine hurts the lowest of the lowest.
The people who dealt with pigs were the lowest of the,
um,
there is a group task contrast between the innkeeper,
their horse and,
and,
and the 19th ceremony for instance.
It's a clash of extremes.
Is there an element of a noble meant in Don Quixote's doggit perception of the
ugly.
Beautiful.
Is there an element?
Uh,
is this one of the reasons the book has endured once a desire to a noble a
reality with one we'll do,
we begin to glimpse here in the madness admission to force them to reality,
his perception of it,
but also notice that because he treats the horse with deference,
they are kind to him as is the innkeeper.
It is a constant.
Instead [inaudible] work that lower class people,
even criminals can be kind in given situations.
There is no class determinism instead of making criminals evil.
Uh,
uh,
quite the contrary,
he's over all the is over.
Oh,
vision of humankind is a positive one.
No one is completely evil in Cervantes.
In this he is very different from Shakespeare and he's sober conception of the
human.
If we are going to believe my very dear friend Harold and his version of
Shakespeare and Shakespeare,
the invention of the Human Cervantes says view of humanity is not a somber and
you will discover this as you read the book.
It is also at the end,
however,
that Don Quixote is turned for the first time into an object of amusement.
The innkeeper plays along to have something to laugh at that night,
uh,
are not the innkeeper and the other guests in need of amusement like the idal
reader.
That's Advantis addresses.
Uh,
here is another level of which don't be haughty is going to provide a amusement.
The ceremony of the Knights of Don Quixote is a parody of those in the books of
Cherry in the romances of chivalry.
But do we not begin to notice in this scene a certain degree of cruelty toward
Don Quixote on the part of other characters and of Servantez himself?
There is.
So this is something that Jorge Luis Borges has degraded.
Argentine writer has remarked upon there certain crooners sometimes in in the
way that that Cervantes portrays his characters.
There is a hint that trying to do the good can be ridiculous and that no good
deed goes on punished as it were,
but it,
this is so chiefly,
I think because of Oakey.
Horta is a living anachronism he has of justice that are outmoded.
Now in the original,
the contrast between Don Quixote on the other characters is achieved by means of
the manners of speech and dialectical contrasts.
We will see that in a minute in his fight with the basket.
I call him what Jarvis cost him something else and we'll get into that in a
minute.
Okay.
Hold a speech turns to the our cake when he speaks about matters of chivalry,
he uses our cake words drawn from the romances of chivalry.
MMM.
This is a very important part,
uh,
of,
surrenders his achievement that is lost in the translation,
but that the,
uh,
English,
reader can gauge.
That is the differentiation between the characters are among the characters by
the way they speak.
You can gauge it by thinking of a novel that was very much influenced by
Cervantes.
The Adventures of Huckleberry Finn Speech marks the characters by providing
their social station and even region of origin.
And we will see that in a minute.
Uh,
I read the adventures of Huckleberry Finn as a child,
first in Spanish,
and of course they didn't translate into the Spanish that dialect differences
between Jim and Hawk and so forth.
I still like the normal very much.
And then when I read it,
once I had learned English in college,
I was astonished.
It was like another book.
Uh,
and I had a,
uh,
a great deal of difficulty understanding Jim's a speech.
This is prevalent in the whole taste.
Perhaps the first novel in which this is accomplished.
Okay.
The inkeeper is himself like a literary character and a kind of haughty in that
he tells of his youth,
which is a youth,
uh,
youth misspent as a picker row.
Uh,
as if it had been a romance of chivalry.
He uses the rhetoric of the romance of chill.
Everyone has of jewelry to tell of his life of,
of petty crime.
And,
uh,
he's a minor,
don't want who's seduces widows and stuff like that.
He,
he says with great pride and he mentions the places where is he,
where he had been as if,
as if they were great places.
And they are really the most notorious and Poria work we're pickers met in
Spain.
Uh,
so he took them play Don Quixote's rhetorical game and he's kind of,
when I came verted mirror image of Don Quixote here,
uh,
you have to read carefully is around,
this is very subtle in creating these characters.
And here we have this character,
uh,
sort of,
marking,
but at the same time,
uh,
using Don Quixote's,
rhetoric,
uh,
to transform his life,
into something important.
Uh,
so,
but so,
so there is a kind of a synthesis in this character between the rhetoric of the
romance of chivalry and the picaresque.
This is what's the renders achieves through these,
uh,
very interesting character.
Now,
the [inaudible] is obviously a kind of baptism.
Uh,
it is a parody of similar ceremonies in the romances of Chabrier's.
I've said,
uh,
it is true that it is a parody,
but in the fictitious world on Don Quixotes creating it has a certain aura of
sacredness.
Nevertheless,
the act completes the process of self invention that began in the first chapter.
It legitimizes it within that world.
With this,
with the ceremony of his being knighted courses be knighted by a ridiculous
retired big row in this,
in surrounded by horse and so forth.
But nevertheless,
in the,
it has an aura of sacredness,
and he finally achieved knighthood.
Now the two episodes in the road after the 19,
intensify moral issues that Don Quixote's madness brings up.
Why,
why does this madness bring up,
uh,
these moral issues?
Because in his madness,
he refuses to abide,
to recognize and to accept social conventions.
And that way he highlights the arbitrariness of such conventions,
uh,
mad men and children do that by asking why,
why,
or by acting as if they don't care.
Why.
And then bringing out that these conventions are indeed conventional.
And this is why Gnocchi holder will once and again,
uh,
create,
more of a crisis
with one.
I'll doodle.
I doodle is the fellow who flogging,
uh,
undress his servant,
for having,
according to him,
for having stolen from him,
some of his,
uh,
animals.
Uh,
with one I'll do [inaudible] dokey hotel trusts in a kind of honesty that does
not exist anymore or perhaps never existed except in the books of,
of,
of chivalry.
Uh,
his intervention makes matters worse as we know.
this is the first of several episodes in which the reader's seems to be invited
to judge,
uh,
who is right.
And the rest there are hints that undressed may very well be in rogue that role,
uh,
and that he may have indeed stolen from his master,
in which case,
according to the laws of the land,
I'll do the,
had every right to flog him.
In fact,
when undressed appears later on and he will re up here,
he is on his way to Seville.
That's a telltale sign because [inaudible] was the center of picaresque life.
Now think of Seville,
us being a,
a very,
very important port in Spain because it was through Seville.
Read your Elliot that Spain communicated with.
It's overseas and Pyre.
Everything came in through Loserville,
which is,
you know,
up there,
we're lucky me river that you're protected in that sense.
So really was a teaming port and ports are always full of corruption and uh,
uh,
and the like,
because of all of the exchange of goods and the various peoples who are there.
So Seville was known for being a center of bigger as life.
So these details around this throws in there when,
when undress appears later and he's going to civilian job,
this is a bigger,
so he may have been,
uh,
so he may have been guilty when I'll do go whips him.
Uh,
Don Quixote is applying a justice that is anachronistic because by this time
Spain had a very well developed and thorough,
uh,
criminal justice system,
very thorough and very well developed.
Uh,
all of these matters,
uh,
found their way.
Uh,
it was a litigious society almost as much as the United States is a litigious
society nowadays.
Uh,
so the way that he intervenes is totally anachronistic.
Now with the top level merchants,
uh,
the conflict texts on a more philosophical,
even doctrinaire CAC,
he didn't know it is a hilarious episode.
This is where he appears before these merchants and says that they have to
declare that [inaudible] was a beautiful lady in the world.
And,
uh,
at a distance,
he's saying this and one of them who is a,
who is a bit of a jester disadvantageous interject.
You have to see how these people said,
well,
wait a minute,
could you at least shows some kind of a picture or something that we can gauge
this by?
Because she may have some stuff pouring out of her eye and don't be older,
says not important or MRI.
And then he charges whether the reverse in Antioch falls and all this is totally
hilarious,
uh,
episode.
Um,
but uh,
can one belief but one cannot see,
see what is behind this episode.
What is the role of sensorial experience in questions of believe?
Isn't there also potentially a social religious subtext here?
Is it not likely that these merchants from Toledo are Jews or converted Jews?
There's Jews who have been forced to convert.
Then is then is the test of which they are being subjected,
not playing with the issue of conversion of forced conversion.
It also seems to allude to fierce debates in the 16th century about religious
images,
which the Protestants did not allow and the Catholics did and,
and so forth.
This is a,
the stakes are getting higher.
And as I explained in an earlier lecture,
Servantez presents,
it's higher stakes,
always in a light rain.
And a very humorous episode was still this,
uh,
issues are there
now.
Don't get hold.
Of course,
it's beaten to a pulp by one of the servants.
This is the ultimate insult and humiliation to be bitten by a commoner,
uh,
after I haven't been betrayed by [inaudible],
they just cannot really move from a truck to a gallop without falling.
And you will see that,
that similar things happen in,
in,
in the future.
So Don Quixote is picked up by Pedro Alonzo.
Notice the common names.
Cervantes gives very common names to where he common people,
Pedro alone.
So it's like being called Peter Johnson or something like that.
So these parallels is one of his neighbors.
He picks him up and noticed he's kindness,
not only in picking up poor,
uh,
along of Hannah as he sees him or his neighbor,
but also in waiting until dark before going into the village to that people
would not see don Quixote in this condition.
Again,
it's an act of kindness on the part of,
uh,
a very low class,
a character.
This is what I was saying before about a characters in Cervantes,
no matter what their social class,
being able to perform these acts of kindness,
there are echoes of the Good Samaritan and so forth.
And the Bible,
if you want to see biblical echoes in the Quixote.
I have to tell you a brief story.
When a close relative of mine was in the hospital,
very ill and I used to go see him.
I used to spend the time sometimes,
uh,
reading the Kihatha and I would get on the elevator sometimes with Mikey Hoff
like this,
and there will be ministers who are also,
we're also there to see dying patients.
Uh,
most of them actually likes to say African American ministers.
And they would see me with the book and I would not,
uh,
as if our knowledge in that I was one of their cards.
Uh,
so,
uh,
now don Quixote's matter than ever because of the beaten,
he has been administered,
uh,
and,
he begins to return home.
Uh,
the return returns home always problematic.
Presumably one is returning to the familiar to the county,
but now the house is going to turn into some very uncanny,
uh,
place.
Uh,
uh,
it is the house where most remember is also the of the abode of the books.
It houses the books that are the source of Loki Jihad.
This is madness.
So it is the familiar,
uh,
the home,
but also the place where the source of his madness is contained.
It is also the place of resource battles as we learn where he would get up in
the middle of the night and begin slashing,
uh,
with his,
with his sword.
And as we will see in a minute,
and as I'm sure you read,
it is a very malleable place.
Uh,
this house changes.
I see if the county were also the uncanny are playing here.
The background on my commentary here is this is the great essay by Freud on the
uncanny become kindly,
uh,
he's theory being that the uncanny is the canny,
the familiar becoming suddenly unfamiliar,
not something totally unfamiliar with the familiar becoming certainly
unfamiliar.
And this is what is happening here,
uh,
with his,
with his house,
uh,
houses,
and shelters,
ins,
palaces,
and all of those are very important in the Quixote.
And I,
I,
I urge you to take a notice of them,
uh,
now,
either here or after the scrutiny is where the hotel was going to end according
to one of the theories that is contained in your,
in your book,
the essay by men in their speed dial.
I will talk about that at the end of the scrutiny.
But this is,
this is a very important point that I want to make today to do or to speak about
that in any case,
uh,
this return home brings up the issue of repetition.
Uh,
uh,
which leads to the philosophical question of whether they can be repetition and
the aesthetic problem of representation.
Because representing is also always a form of repetition,
repeating something.
Um,
and the issue of representation is at the core of the questions about literature
that's Advantis brings up throughout the whole book.
It also dovetails with donkey hold his own project to revive the heroic age.
Can,
something can be revived,
can be,
can it be,
repeat it.
Uh,
the return also allows for a fuller analysis of Don Quixote is madness.
The housekeeper underneath related ventures of Don Quixote is prior to his first
Sally.
The needs recounts how he would read for two days and nights with straight
without rest.
We're upon,
he would draw his sword on flail I see in the battle until exhausted.
Steady.
They return allows us to learn more about the etiology,
the origin of donkey hope.
This is a madness.
Uh,
the literary madness is not sufficient for Cervantes.
and so he seems to have the need us.
Remember when I mentioned that,
what are the sound once book by the doctor that I mentioned who wrote examining
Haniel's.
This gives us some details about don Quixote's fees,
physical qualities,
and all of that that make the,
the,
uh,
that make him,
prone to madness.
For instance,
he's,
he's thinness.
The dryness of his skin.
Dry Constitution in the theory was humorous of the time of medicine at the time,
made him,
uh,
a candidate for the kind of madness that here this is because,
Cervantes on like Dante who's divine comedy is thoroughly allegorical,
uh,
Sarandis only free flirts with allegory but always seems to avoid it.
What I mean is this is not an allegorical madman.
This is a particular madman with a specific illness,
not an every man who can easily be subsumed in the week at the beginning of the
divine comedy.
And they'll met.
So they'll come in Nostra Savita Nostra we tie in the middle of a journey of our
lives.
This is,
this,
this particular,
uh,
Matt Man,
this is why all these details about his life at home are given his diet and all
of that.
Our details around this are given to justify to his madness and just the
literary madness.
Now the book burning and the walling of the library will be curious for donkey
holders,
madness,
but both are also filled with all kinds of implications.
But through both parts of the,
of,
of the novel,
uh,
the characters will be,
searching for cures for donkey Quixote.
Uh,
and here obviously the burning of the books and the walling off of the library
are a part of the,
of the cure.
You eliminate the source and you eliminate the illness.
Now,
the inquisition of the library or the scrutiny of a library is one of the most
famous episodes in the Quixote.
And of course one of the favorite ones of literary critics and historians
because he deals with books.
Um,
again,
it is conjecture that the end of the library episode would have been the end of
the Novella of Don Quixote if indeed what's Advantis proposed to write was a
long short story about,
uh,
don't get this man who goes mad from bleeding too much,
etc. And then this novella would end here.
Uh,
and that would have been it.
He wrote many of those shortened oilettes.
We published 12 of them in,
in 16,
13.
He called them extemporary stories.
It is conjecture,
but you will read it in many industry doll,
uh,
essay that this was going to be the Hilton and that Cervantes,
took stock of the fact that there were the character and the situation had great
possibilities and continued from then on.
Uh,
he's normal.
now one can buy all the way back.
I get back to that in a minute.
Uh,
that the,
the Eh,
the inquiry of the library is of course,
uh,
a satire of the Spanish inquisition.
This is clear.
They put the Spanish inquisition also for bid books,
picked up books and burned books.
So,
uh,
it is a mile of satire.
I hear the English edition is represented by uh,
uh,
the niece who's 19 years old,
the housekeeper,
a village priest at Barbara.
I mean these are not exactly a high intellect and the inquisition,
uh,
they positions officers were so,
so this is a satire instead of anthis even against menacing institutions like
the inquisition,
these always mild.
It's always mild,
never,
uh,
very,
bitter.
Now details that are somewhat important about the,
the,
the scrutiny of the library is that notebook in it,
in the library was published after 1591.
So that allows us to surmise that the hotel was written after 19 1591.
The chapter is the bibliography that Cervantes refused to provide in the
prologue.
Remember when his friend says you don't have to,
you can make it up.
Well,
this is the,
this is the bibliography.
Uh,
of course,
he couldn't have given this radiography in the prologue because it'd be
biography made off of romances of chivalry is not a very,
uh,
authoritative bibliography.
I said,
worry is not Aristotle,
Plato and Saint Thomas Aquinas,
but I'm at least their gala and so forth.
Uh,
so,
uh,
what he's giving here are the sources of donkey Quixote's madness.
And,
uh,
he's,
he's caring.
He's protagonist literary genealogy.
This is the,
the family background that he refuses to provide about Loki Hotez,
quote unquote real family.
Now,
what has donkey,
how to read?
Well,
devalued romances,
but also renaissance.
Epic's,
uh,
pastoral romances and some serious poetry.
What is missing from this library?
Religious books,
classics and religious books.
Uh,
there are no devotional books in this library as one we'll find in the library
of Diego than me.
Danda a character in the second part,
uh,
who says that he has devotional books.
Now,
of course,
most American readers are astonished that there is no Bible,
but this is Catholic,
Spain and in Catholic countries,
we don't read the Bible.
We read devotional books or hear the Bible in sermons from the priests.
So of course it's this.
If this were a library in New England or in Old England,
they would have been a bible,
but no Bible,
uh,
here at all.
But no devotional books either.
What's these means?
Is that along Saki.
Hannah is a belated human,
is that,
it's a humanist that came at the end of humanism,
lack Cervantes himself a Christian with a weakness for a frivolous literature,
but not very piles or devout.
Okay.
Although it is true for a human is there are no classics here either.
They're very little poetry.
Although Don Quixote's throughout the,
the novel seems to know a lot about poetry and even composers and poetry.
There's nothing by the Great Gfsi Lasso,
the important Petrarch on style part of the 16th century in Spain who was a
model of poets and to whom Don Quixote alludes all the time.
Somehow it is missing this,
this library does not give the whole range of the rant.
This is readings or even of Don Quixote's is uh,
uh,
reading what prevail are the romances of chivalry,
about whom,
uh,
about which I spoke in the last class for them,
for lucky did,
they represented a world of absolute values in a fake pass and place,
uh,
where there is no fish fish.
Your don't break between the imagination desire and the real,
uh,
now in fact is that very few romances of chivalry appeared in Spain after 1565
said lantus was born in 1547.
This book appears in 1605.
The action supposedly takes place in the 1590s.
So in this don Quixote is also a bit out of fashion.
These romances or chivalry seems to be,
seem to be already a little out of fashion,
but things move slowly.
And the fact is that many characters in the novel appear to have read the
romances of chivalry and to be very conversant with the romances of chivalry.
Um,
so,
uh,
what else do we have?
Pastoral Romances,
Pastor Romances,
uh,
where stories of fake shepherds,
people playing the role of shepherds from the backlogs,
logs of antiquity,
uh,
involved in amorous adventures,
in,
in neoplatonic,
uh,
fashion going through a,
a beautiful,
uh,
in beautiful natural settings that corresponded to the who to the purity of
their love and this and that.
And yet they could lead to tragic consequences.
And this is as you will,
as you will see in the Marcel Andrew [inaudible] episode that is coming up very
soon.
Uh,
these romances of pastoral Romances I know are the furthest away from the modern
sensibility.
One can imagine a modern,
uh,
chief Valerie Romance.
But I mentioned,
I talked about James Bond and the Fleming movies and all of that,
but he's almost impossible to think of a modern pastoral.
It's not,
not impossible,
but very improbable.
Um,
but this is one of the roles that don't get hot.
They could have chosen to play.
And in fact,
later on in the novel,
he will try to become a shepherd to,
he will think of becoming a shepherd to now,
whom does set Avantis surprisingly include among the authors in the,
uh,
in donkey health library
set of vomitus himself.
He had said,
well,
I'm just himself.
Uh,
they got a lot there.
The Jarvis rights.
Michael,
this Advantis said the Barbara that's Advantis has been a great friend of mine
these many years and I know that he is better acquainted with misfortune and
stand with poetry.
His book has somewhat of good invention.
It,
he's talking about Cervantes is pastoral romance.
Like he proposes something but concludes nothing.
We must wait for the second part,
which he promises perhaps on his amendment,
he may obtain that entire partner and so forth.
Uh,
so this is,
uh,
a wink,
a of this to the reader in which he's inviting us to sort of fall in the same,
uh,
error as don Quixote blaring literature and reality.
This is what happens when said Vantis the author whose name is imprinted on the,
on the cover of the book a within the fiction of the book,
the,
the distinction between fiction and reality to be doing literature in reality is
blurred.
And Cervantes is,
is,
uh,
intimating that the reading of Literature in general can lead to such,
confusion.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
all of these,
as I will explain in a minute,
all always the self referential things are very funny,
but they have behind a very serious,
uh,
ideas.
Now
notice also the irony that both the priest and the barber are steeped in the
romances of Chivel.
They are readers of the romances of jewelry.
They know them very well.
They defend some,
and the priests speaks of having even begun to write one.
We will find more readers.
So the romances of chivalry and more potential riders of romantic romances of
chivalry through the novel.
I notice the elaborate lie that the niece comes up with to explain the
disappearance of the library from the house.
It is a,
it is astonishing offenders.
He has don Quixote's,
the maybe it runs in the family,
uh,
and an old man riding a snake leaves a trail of smoke.
I hope you,
uh,
you noticed this,
a marvelous passage,
uh,
where,
the niece says,
uh,
well the,
the incubator says that it does,
that it was a devil.
The Carter,
he was not the devil said Denise on page 55,
but an enchanter who came on one night up on a cloud after the day of your
departure is gs addressing donkey haughty,
uh,
hence and alighting from a serpent on which he wrote,
entered into the room.
And I know not what he did there,
but after some little time out,
he came flying through the roof and left the house full of smoke.
Okay.
And when we went to see what he had been doing,
we saw,
we saw neither books,
no room only.
We were well re the only week very well,
remember both I and mistress housekeeper here that when the old thief went away,
he said with a loud voice that for a secret and meaty e board to the owner of
those books.
I know the room.
He had done it.
This shift in this house,
we should sue be manifest.
He told us also that he,
he was called the [inaudible] free stone.
He meant to say quote Don Quixote Sad.
Okay.
How'd it doesn't?
Of course,
that's in question.
The reality.
He just questions the mispronunciation of the name of the enchanter.
What does it mean that the needs to tell this lie?
The physical disappearance of the library walled off by the housekeeper and the
niece is an instance of the world of reality conspiring to increase Gnocchi,
hottest madness.
And of the uncanny,
the familiar,
the house becoming unfamiliar.
He came and began looking for the,
for the room and running his hands through the wall and couldn't find the door.
Uh,
it has been said that there is a contradiction in this action of walling off the
library when there are no longer any books in it.
But Don Quixote does not know this.
And also it would have been difficult to explain to him that the books had been
burnt or given away.
They were burned.
They were his property.
So they have committed a punishable act,
the barber that breeze the knees and the housekeeper,
a covering their own actions with a fiction ally,
embellished by the nieces wild imagination,
which is contaminated by the romances of chivalry themselves.
This reveals,
notice that said one,
there's us and pillows,
but Geez,
a reader romances of jewelry.
We learned through this,
uh,
speech of hers,
that she is a reader of romances of jewelry and that,
uh,
she suggests that that Ci to,
read is romances probably sneaking into her uncle's library and reading them.
They're secretly,
you see how much Cervantes can suggest without saying it directly.
Yeah.
Now and more significant contradiction is that while the library is walled off
and the book burned,
the character's continued to speak to the Quixote from within the fictions of
jewelry.
They,
they both cure and making more insane or they trying to cure him by because they
realized that he can only be spoken to from within his own mat world.
Um,
Eh,
eh,
Claudio,
a very famous critical unfortunately passed away about a year ago.
Uh,
uh,
since that Don Quixote is enveloped by a written context,
the literary journals or the romances of jewelry,
which to him historically was historically true,
structured by potential adventures that await him home foreseen but appropriate
by virtue of that genre.
Because after this,
Don Quixote does not read another book.
He doesn't even read the book about himself as the characters in part to do when
you get to part two,
one of the fun parts of part two is that the readers,
I mean that the,
the,
the characters are they the,
the protagonist and counter have read part one
on,
they expect Don Quixote to act according to how he acted in part one.
But okay,
hold the,
has not read it.
Sandra has an ear of course because he can read.
But uh,
so Bodak yellow does not read another book after,
uh,
after this,
no central enters the scene.
So he represents European peasant dream from time in memorial.
Saint Joe,
by the way,
is a very common person type of name.
The only one I can come up in English is Wilbur.
I think that a farmer in English would be called Wilbur.
I mean it's an Smith.
Remember that?
A,
that a comic strip.
Uh,
I would imagine someone being called Wilbur.
I Dunno why,
but that's what I imagined.
Centuries is a very,
very common name.
It gives us
a,
chuck always eludes me.
Uh,
it gives us the last name,
Sanchez in Spanish that many of you have heard.
I'm
Sanchez in fact,
uh,
um,
when it has not,
of course you need the accident,
uh,
Spanish names.
That means belonging to the family of century like Johnson Davidson,
the easy in Spanish gonsalo becomes Gonzales.
Grober ego becomes Rodriguez.
Martine becomes Martinez.
You see,
I told you you were going to learn tidbits about Spanish culture and there is
one
how Spanish,
not all Spanish last name.
How this common Spanish last names like Mine Gonzalez,
uh,
now.
So Sanchez Sanchez,
uh,
he banned some means what we belly,
belly gut.
Uh,
it,
it refers to his,
to his eating habits and to his being very much in touch with the matter with
the earth.
Um,
now of course he could represent is common sense in contrast to Don Quixote's
flights of fancy and I mean common sense,
the sense of the common people,
whereas Gnocchi whole days,
a voracious readers,
centuries illiterate,
he has in his head all the oral law.
Uh,
however he expresses this through his friendliness or,
uh,
proverbs as you will see soon,
brothers that are the source of folk wisdom on which the fascinated humanism,
the humanist,
by the way,
because they,
they thought that the pro,
the proverbs,
the roughriders were a form of,
of common philosophy of the people and that that philosophy could potentially
contain as much wisdom as regular philosophy.
That is a book of proverbs in the Bible and a philosopher,
philosophers,
uh,
have used such a,
snippets,
uh,
like [inaudible] in France,
the 17th century who wrote mcsema maxims.
Lover.
Could you Nikki levies diggy say Vishu is nothing but vice.
This guys said [inaudible] Shuko in his first and Maxime Nichie wrote,
uh,
such a short snippets,
to,
uh,
but these are the common people's expressions of wisdom.
Uh,
he essentially will repeat them over and over.
And again,
[inaudible] he drives monkey hot.
They matter because of,
of of them.
He can't take it anymore.
Now in terms of literary history,
essential issues from the world of comedy of the theater of the pickers,
kind of sell Astena some who have wanted to do an allegorical reading of the
Quixote.
Uh,
see it as a,
the pair as an allegory of,
of,
of mine and body Don Quixote in mind,
Sanchez the body.
But the most remarkable thing is that with his appearance,
uh,
the novel's a world becomes one of dialogue dialogue between central and
Oklahoma.
Now
what is most significant about central,
and this will become even more evident in part two,
is that without readings or refinement,
he is nevertheless endowed with sufficient wisdom to live and make valuable
judgment,
carbon sense,
sense of the common people as a sufficient quantity of mind.
This is quite a modern,
uh,
idea leading up to democratic and egalitarian notions that do not reachable
flyer until the enlightenment in the 18th century.
And in,
in,
in philosophers like,
uh,
show a sun dress sense,
his limitations.
And indeed influences his master,
uh,
and his attitudes.
And you will see he engages in dialog.
We don't Quixote.
And although respectful,
he holds his ground because he has a sufficient wisdom to do so.
Now,
so with sanctuary,
the,
uh,
the novel seems to be complete.
Uh,
the cast is complete,
uh,
and,
and the second Sally,
we'll begin here.
And the second Sally,
uh,
is where the hotels,
we know it really begins if,
if,
if it was going to be a short story and Savannah this extended it to become the
Quixote.
It is here that the Quixote as we know,
it begins with sanctuary in place.
So in a sense,
Don Quixote is its own source.
Again,
self legitimation.
Now,
uh,
the adventure of the,
of the windmills I have a little bit more,
uh,
this is a signature episode of the Quixote.
As you know,
you have seen it everywhere,
represent that everywhere you go to the Bata has airport in Madrid and you will
find a thousand little trinkets that you can buy with the windmills and Don
Quixote and so forth.
Hawaii.
It's the first adventure where the two characters,
uh,
disagree about the nature of what is being seen.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
tremendously,
funny.
Uh,
it has one of the most tremendous,
uh,
one of the funniest lines in the whole book for me when Don Quixote.
So look at those with giants and he goes on and on about the giants and with a
pause that,
uh,
that,
good comic who would be able to use Sanchez,
what giants.
He just didn't see any giants.
He sees windmills.
And then so don Quixote,
uh,
charges,
and with a catastrophic result that you,
uh,
that,
you know,
uh,
now there are other things that are important about the scene.
It,
it sets,
uh,
the four part structure of most scenes that will follow a one donkey hotel.
Sanko see something.
Do they argue about what it is?
City don't get.
Hotel takes action for discussing the aftermath of the adventure,
what it was.
And there is the moment also,
uh,
when donkey haunting,
says,
uh,
something quite profound after this,
adventure,
uh,
in trying to explain how the giants became windmills,
he says,
bs friends,
they 60 piece friends sanctu answered,
okay,
hold that for matters of war are of all others.
Most subject to continual mutations,
but don't get hope that he's saying he's quite profound,
is that reality is,
is in a state of flux.
So things may appear to be something now and be something different a moment
later.
So He's,
he's,
he's interpretation is not foolish at all.
He also alludes back to the disappearance of his library.
I mean,
these things can happen.
Hey,
my library and disappear.
This giants come become windmills and I could be,
uh,
on,
on seed it now.
Then the next two episodes,
uh,
are,
um,
a very,
uh,
interesting,
on,
uh,
one is the fight with the,
what Jarvis calls.
They'd be scanner a Basque Biscayne,
or these are people from the Basque country,
the Basque country,
uh,
of the Basques occupy,
parts of Spain and France.
The very proud people because they presumably were never invaded.
First of all,
they have been there since the beginning of time.
Their language cannot be traced back to Indo European sources.
They don't know where it came from.
There,
there and there.
The Romans couldn't,
couldn't take them over and the Arabs couldn't take them over.
So we're very proud of that at other,
very proud of their aristocratic background.
I know about this because my family,
most of it is Basque and a Itchy,
watery eyes,
a Basque name.
So even today,
even today,
they are a bear,
a fright,
frightening people.
They have a,
there is this group Will Atallah you may have heard in Spain,
it is a separatist terrorist group that blows up,
uh,
things and kills people and so forth on both the Spanish and the French
government have been fighting them because the Basque this group,
uh,
want autonomy from Spain and France.
They want their own country.
So this is a background,
this is the first of several characters you're going to meet in the book from
regions other than Castiel.
Uh,
I remember Spain is,
is made up of several regions,
several cultures and languages.
And the Basques are the furthest away from other cultures in the Spanish
peninsula because they don't have a Roman background.
Uh,
their language is,
uh,
as,
as it has nothing to do with romance,
languages enhance.
He speaks funny and part of the humor in this episode is the way he speaks very
broken Spanish and how he acts was a sense of self assurance and heartiness and
so forth because he is Basque.
Um,
I am going to stop there and read just a couple of things from the background
readings and because I want to speak about the lost and found manuscript and all
of that in relation to the,
uh,
self reflective,
reflexive and is in there.
Now I know that and I don't want to do it at the end.
When you and I are tired,
I wanted you to consider,
uh,
this is a way of uh,
encouraging you to read Elliot Elliot in periods pain.
These contrast that Elliot,
uh,
sets up here between Castille and Aragorn,
the crown of Aragon.
Therefore we this rich and energetic urban Patricia.
It was deeply influenced by its overseas commercial interests,
mostly in the Mediterranean.
It was imbued with a contractural concept of the relationship between kings and
subjects,
which had been effectively realize in institutional form and it was well
experience in the administration of Empire.
It was there still are,
they cut.
The lands are very good businessmen in all of these respect.
It contrasted strikingly with Midi evil cause still from which he said well,
uh,
came.
So the queen where in the early 14th century,
the crown of Aragon was cosmopolitan in outlook and predominantly American title
in its inclinations,
Contemporary Castille tended to look inwards rather than outwards,
inwards and was oriented less toward trade than war.
Fundamentally,
Castille was a pastoral and nomadic society whose habits and attitudes had been
shaped by constant warfare against the morse,
by the protracted process of the reconquista.
The reconquest still awaiting completion long after it was finished in the crown
of Aragon.
The point that I want to suggest here is there an echo of this nomadic warlike
quantity of customers in the novel itself where the characters are on the move,
Doki hotel,
Quixote and Sanctu and all the other characters who are on the move.
This is reflection of this character of Castilian society as Elliot describes it
here.
This is just to give you an idea of how productive the reading of Elliot can be
for this book.
The other,
uh,
texts that I want to to read is from Manuel do rounds essay,
on the life of sort of Lantus or is at the beginning of a case book.
Now this is just a very brief life of around this one cannot go much further
even though there be many biographies because there are no documents were very
few documents to be found.
Now of course there were more,
much more documents than he checks me as case.
Uh,
but nothing new has been fun.
And,
uh,
I think that what is important,
do things are important in what,
uh,
Duran says here,
one,
he suggests more than sestad Cervantes.
I think I've mentioned this before,
belongs to the first generation of writers who are professional writers.
Before you had aristocrats and you hire the clergy who could write because they
had the leisure time to do it.
They were idle,
uh,
readers
and writers,
uh,
not Serratus,
serratus depends on,
on,
on aristocrats,
uh,
in the,
in the old style of,
of,
of the nbcs who gives you money.
But it was very unsuccessful that way and it was very poor.
And the,
the,
the publisher swindled him out of money and he was poor and he worked on was in
jail and so forth.
As you have read in that snippet,
it was in jail for his,
he's accounts who are not too clear and when he was doing as a tax collector and
all of that.
So these are the first professional writers.
And the second point is,
uh,
even more important,
which is about how said went this was both inside and outside Spanish society
instead of Lantus.
But if if said,
this is [inaudible] speaking,
he sort of,
one,
it's Advantis biography teaches us anything.
It is that he was at the same time inside and outside the mainstream of Spanish
life as an insider.
He took part in the battle of Lepanto and wrote at last at least two successful
books don't get hauled down the exemplary novels.
This is certainly much more than the level of achievement of a more of most
middle class.
It algos of his time as an outsider.
He was always poor,
almost in the point of being,
to the point of being destitute and not infrequently in jail.
He lacked influential friends in a society where nothing could be done without
them.
And without money.
He was often unable to protect adequately the female members of his family.
The influential critics and writers of his time did not recognize the of his
work.
His accomplishments as a soldier and as a loyal member of the administration
were ignored.
While he's,
while he's every minor transgression was punished harshly.
This is a,
a good point about set a month,
this,
uh,
figure who's both inside and outside society and hence can provide these deep
probe into that society.